kind of love this one my teen
purposely pushes my buttons your teen is
not consciously pushing your buttons
playing certain sports can make your
teen grow taller if there were a sport
like that everyone would probably be
doing that sport parents shouldn't talk
to their kids about sex children have
riskier behavior when they don't talk to
their parents about sex and sexuality
it's not the reverse hi i'm dr blair
hammond general pediatrician at mount
sinai hospital where i've been for 18
years i'm also the co-founding director
and director of medical education of the
mount sinai parenting center hi i'm dr
elisa pressman i'm a developmental
psychologist i'm an assistant clinical
professor at mount sinai hospital and
the other co-founder of the mount sinai
parenting center i'm also the host of
the podcast raising good humans today
we'll be debunking myths about parenting
teens and we're both parents of teens
yes
adolescence
starts at 13 and ends at 18.
this is a myth
it feels very comfortable to keep
adolescence in a small window puberty
can start as early as eight or nine it
doesn't just end at 18 where their
prefrontal cortex is at full growth and
they're ready to go out into the world
they still are
experiencing changes
into their 20s and this prefrontal
cortex that we talk about is this area
right in the front part of the brain
that's involved with judgment inhibition
even morality it's important to remember
that adolescence is a time of tremendous
growth in fact it's the second largest
brain growth period after that first
zero to three period
all teenagers are risk takers who want
to try drugs and alcohol
this is not true certainly adolescence
is a risk-taking time as we know and
it's a time of experimenting but many
adolescents do not try alcohol or drugs
one thing that happens in adolescence is
they are more all gas and no breaks and
so it can
mean that their impulse control isn't
mature enough to make decisions
particularly with groups of other
adolescents and the other thing to
remember is that the teenage brain hyper
rationalizes so their tendency
is to look at the positive outcome so if
you're going to get into a car and
you've been with people who are drinking
you've been drinking an adolescent brain
that's hyper rationalizing is going to
say there's only a 10 chance that
something bad will happen what you want
them to do is move to just thinking the
bigger picture what does that 10 percent
look like and is that what i want for
another human being or me putting their
life at danger putting my life at danger
and of course the answer is no strict
parents raise well-behaved children
if we could change this to strict
parents sometimes raise well-behaved
children in front of them that would be
the only way this would be true strict
controlling parents
may have kids who seem like they behave
but they have covert behaviors
that are terrifying because they are
more scared of getting in trouble with
you
than they are the actual danger if you
have no boundaries and expectations you
also can get kids who get into a lot of
trouble and make poor decisions high
expectations of children is great having
boundaries setting limits for your child
in a warm and sensitive way where you
collaborate and you're like okay does
this seem reasonable what's considered
authoritative parenting
you are less likely to have kids who act
out and misbehave in ways that are
dangerous i think that's what every
parent is trying
to teach their child to have that
intrinsic motivation
to
make good choices on their own teens are
addicted to social media for a lot of
teens
it's not about addiction it's just about
connection addiction happens when you
get rewards intermittently and you keep
seeking those rewards and you can't stop
yourself from wanting to seek those
rewards and i think the word addiction
is commonly used when it interferes with
a teen's ability to function or to do
other things they want to do that's when
it becomes something that you need to
look at more seriously and then the
other thing is
remember more than what you say what you
do influences what your children do and
so how can you make it something that
you both sort of learn together and so
it seems more of a discussion and a
collaborative
decision about social media playing
certain sports can make your teen grow
taller that is actually a myth if there
were a sport like that everyone would
probably be doing that sport so sports
like volleyball and tennis might give
the appearance because it is helpful to
be tall in those sports but it is not
the sport that has actually made them
taller the number one thing is actually
genetics so looking at the height of
each parent
we talk about something called mid
parental height it is important to get
good nutrition adequate calories calcium
and vitamin d and also getting good
sleep at night to help with growth i
encourage sports but unfortunately the
reason for encouraging sports is not to
make your child taller playing video
games
will rot your teen's brain mostly a myth
so of course the research on video games
and
phones and social media is tricky
because there are a lot of confounding
variables but for the most part the
damage from video games that people talk
about are being sedentary that so much
time sitting is very bad for kids and
that violent video games are
connected with or associated with
more aggressive behavior but actually
only slightly teenagers do connect over
video games which is something different
than when we grew up playing video games
they now have these headsets and it's a
way for them to actually have social
interactions instead of thinking of
video games as all bad try to understand
them and maybe even play them with your
team so that if that's something that
they're into they can explain to you
what's so exciting about it and play it
with you teens don't need to take
vitamins
i would say
for some this is a myth some teenagers
they have very healthy diets and they
get everything they need
from their diets but there are a fair
amount of teenagers who are actually
deficient most commonly in vitamin d and
in iron especially menstruating teens so
iron is something you need for your red
blood cells if you are bleeding every
month you are using
up red blood cells and eating more iron
stores and it's also been shown recently
to help prevent inflammation iron is
often high in meats green leafy
vegetables but if your child is having
heavy periods in particular that can
make them at increased risk for being
iron deficient and in that case i would
recommend a multivitamin my teen
purposely
pushes my butt your teen is not
consciously pushing your buttons they
need to move away from their primary
caregivers and toward their peers that's
part of the natural evolution of being a
teen it hurts
the other reason is to vent and they
need an outlet and they need a place to
just let go so oftentimes it feels
personal they're pushing your buttons
but actually you are their safe haven
they know you're not going anywhere no
matter what they say to you hopefully
the repair is more important than the
disconnect and that strengthens the
relationship
and also builds their skill
at
coming together after a disconnect
parents shouldn't talk to their kids
about sex this is a common myth actually
that if you talk to your kids about sex
you're going to make them more
interested in sex but actually
what has been shown is that parents who
talk to their children about sex and
have open discussions have kids more
likely to engage in sex later
and are more likely to practice safe sex
meaning decreased risk of sexually
transmitted diseases decreased risk of
teen pregnancy children have riskier
behavior when they don't talk to their
parents about sex and sexuality it's not
the reverse not talking about something
does not stop a behavior and in fact it
can be dangerous
you want to be a person that they can
ask questions to and that you can help
them find the knowledge because if you
don't they have the internet they have
many ways to look it up on their own
and they can also feel like you're
disapproving and are not interested if
you never bring it up there is no one
right age to start talking about sex but
what can be important is thinking about
relationships about communication about
bodies about
puberty about sexuality about intimacy
and those are going to be part of a long
and wonderful relationship that you're
going to have with your child because
you're an askable parent
being depressed is a natural part of
being a teenager first of all it is
absolutely true
that teenagers feel feelings bigger
and so they come across sometimes as
more emotionally charged so a sadness
that occurs might sound like a louder
sadness and that can be confusing
when you actually have a teenager who's
experiencing depression versus a
teenager who's experiencing the natural
much higher highs and lower lows that
are part of the adolescent brain
separately
depression is an epidemic
in adolescence 80
of the diagnoses in adults
were available and visible in
adolescence depression is so common as
you mentioned especially right now sadly
suicide is the second leading cause of
death in children ages 10 to 24. and
there are specific symptoms
of depression if they're really feeling
sadness to the point where they lose
interest in things they're usually
interested in if they're socially
withdrawn depression can present as
irritability if you have a child who
seems really angry and really irritable
that should be something you should
investigate further and have them talk
about their feelings it lets them know
that you're interested in knowing how
they feel and where they are and if you
have suspicions that your child might be
having depression
please make sure you contact their
doctor and let them know because there
is such great treatment out there i also
try and encourage every teen to think
about mental health
like they think about physical health in
a preventive way exercising every day
helps release endorphins and neural
chemicals which make people feel better
and happier that's important teens are
lazy
all teens are lazy is actually a myth
one of the reasons why teens are
perceived as lazy is because they have
an altered sleep wake schedule their
circadian rhythm is different so your
team when you want them to wake up at 7
00 a.m to go to school seems so sleepy
and lazy and unmotivated however if you
wanted to have a really in-depth
conversation with them at 1am they might
be really into it and that of course is
because of the altered sleep cycle of
teens only girls struggle with eating
disorders
eating disorders do not only occur in
girls body image is a big thing for
teens really in general and obsessions
with being thin
is classically thought of with anorexia
nervosa where people have restrictive
eating and they take in less and have
significant weight loss and still have
this
obsessive thinking that they are not
thin enough and have to lose more weight
there's bulimia which is binge eating
and purging either through vomiting
or using laxatives and then there's
exercise disorders and so some of these
other types of eating disorders you
wouldn't be able to tell just looking at
them of course building muscles and
being physically fit is good for your
bone strength but we want to emphasize
it from a position of health and
wellness and balance and another thing
is there is a genetic and behavioral
link between parental eating disorders
and adolescent eating disorders and so
if you have an unchecked eating disorder
there's a great motivator to get help so
that you can model healthy eating
behaviors boys will be boys we've all
learned that this is a ridiculous
statement except people still say it so
what do they mean i think it's a
justification for a lot of negative
unhealthy behaviors when
parents feel out of control and they
can't figure out what to do with their
son they might
say something like boys will be boys
they're talking about excusing impulse
control behavior problems they're
talking about
how there are myths about boys sexuality
and their developing sex drive and how
they're looking at other people
and none of those things are actually
true are there differences between
female and male birth assignment
and adolescent developing brains there
are minor differences when you look at
the statistics they're not big enough to
brush it off as boys will be boys and
it's super toxic to blame behaviors and
have lower expectations of an adolescent
simply because their sex assignment with
birth
was male the only person you can control
is you
and so as a parent you have to think of
how you can change your actions
to help your child remembering that the
adolescent brain is going through a huge
huge amount of growth changes and
renovations
and that with your support and
understanding
along with all of the appropriate
boundaries that you provide
they're gonna do great
yeah i i love parenting and adolescent
me too